Dan.
Komputer quantum sangat sensitif terhadap hingar
gangguan yang boleh menyebabkan ralat
dalam pengiraan mereka, tapi kajian terbaru menunjukkan
komputer quantum berising IBM menyamai kaedah klasik yang tepat
dan mengatasi dalam rejim yang boleh disahkan serta menjalankan kaedah klasik canggih
pengiraan hampiran dalam kedua-dua rejim yang boleh disahkan
dan yang tidak boleh disahkan
untuk eksperimen simulasi yang mencabar.
Macam mana mereka buat ni? Mereka guna teknik khas
untuk menangani hingar
dalam sistem quantum — ia dipanggil pengurangan ralat.
Dengan teknik pengurangan ralat
yang digunakan dalam eksperimen ini, kita jalankan pengiraan kita
sambil perlahan-lahan menaikkan tahap hingar.
Kemudian kita ekstrapolasi balik ke tahap hingar sifar.
Kerja ini membawa kita selangkah lebih dekat kepada pengkomputeran quantum yang berguna
kita